this is where the FIFA World Cup final
will soon be held the Lucille stadium in
Qatar in just four years it went from
this to this
it has 80 000 seats and cost more than
700 million dollars to build it's the
biggest stadium in the Middle East but
it's more than that over a decade ago
Qatar had hoped that hosting a mega
sporting event in stadiums like these
would put it on the map but today
stadiums like Lucille are a symbol of
how a country can build grand
infrastructure to further its own
interests and how those Ambitions can
trap thousands Margaret workers lost
their lives in the construction of the
Stadium's forced through Labor under
extremely poor conditions migrants
working on infrastructure projects have
died or suffered abuse
[Music]
The Logical source of oil for Europe is
the Middle East
since the 1940s when Qatar discovered
huge reserves of oil and then gas it's
been one of the richest countries on
Earth
70 percent of the government's Revenue
comes from oil and gas exports thanks to
all that wealth Qatar has gone through a
remarkable transformation the capital of
Doha for instance went from fishing town
to world-class City in just a couple of
decades complete with extraordinary
museums and fancy hotels but in recent
years the world has been turning to
renewable energy making the oil and gas
market Qatar relies on even less
dependable and in the Gulf the country
has seen Regional tensions search most
notably in 2017 when neighboring
countries issued a blockade against
Qatar cutting off trade and travel it
cost the country hundreds of millions of
dollars
foreign
so to diversify and protect its economy
Qatar has started leaning into another
area that helped establish its status as
a wealthy Nation
Sports
that repositioning is based on soft
power Qatar is trying to secure friends
when in need particularly powerful
friends from the West like the United
States and the UK and so the best way to
do that is through these soft sectors
like sports in the last 18 years Qatar
has held more than 20 major sporting
events but nothing compares to the 2022
World Cup
the winner is Qatar
Qatar won the rights to host the World
Cup in 2010. today we celebrate but
tomorrow
the work begins it had made an
unbeatable promise to FIFA it would
spend more money than any host had ever
done before 200 billion dollars and it
delivered
since then Qatar has built up eight
stadiums it's built dozens of hotels and
laid down miles of roads and Metro lines
to connect all that infrastructure
they've even completed a whole new city
with golf courses marinas and a theme
park it can brag that it is the first
Middle Eastern country that's ever
hosted a mega sporting event to be able
to do that you have a lot of Partners
including FIFA itself and all the
celebrity ambassadors who are vouching
for Qatar having these incredible
world-class stadiums these glowing
glistening hotels you can come to Doha
and feel secure that you're experiencing
a world that's business savvy that's
modern and advanced while the spotlight
was supposed to show Qatar as a shining
example of development it also exposed
one of its darkest secrets
to power Decades of development Qatar
has relied on a constant supply of
temporary low-paid workers mainly from
South Asia and East Africa since the
early 2000s so many foreigners have come
to work in Qatar they now make up 80
percent of the total population they
build clean serve and staff pretty much
every industry when we think about how
migrant workers recruitment Journey
commences we think about workers who are
in extremely low wage situations so they
are looking for a case where they can
emigrate to allow them some upwards
socio-economic mobility and Qatar
promises them that Mobility typically
Qatari companies hire International
recruitment agencies that find workers
to send over they promise these workers
well-paying jobs in exchange for illegal
recruitment fees up front they also have
the workers pay for medical tests
passports flights the Visa all to get
the job contract the workers often take
out loans in their home countries to pay
the agencies incurring significant debt
to huge transnational
cross-border operation which completely
screws workers at the start of their
Journey workers often use their family's
savings to pay for a job in one of the
richest countries per capita in the
world they arrive in Qatar often to find
they're not getting the job and salary
promised and can't do anything about it
because they've now entered the
country's kafala system
it's a uniquely restrictive immigration
system that can take different forms in
different Industries but they all have
one crucial thing in common kafala
legally ties the immigrants integration
status to their employer meaning an
individual employer has to sponsor their
worker which gives them an inordinate
amount of power over them they can
control when their employees job ends or
if they can change jobs they can control
if and when migrants leave the country
Often by confiscating their passports
and they can also control the workers
ability to renew their residency and
work permit
but beyond the restrictions on a
migrant's freedom of movement this
system also traps them in a cycle of
abuse and that became evident when Qatar
started preparing for the World Cup
[Music]
to deliver on the infrastructure Qatar
promised it tapped into its migrant
Pipeline and recruited hundreds of
thousands of new workers when cancer was
awarded the World Cup in 2010 all of the
people involved in the decision-making
knew that the World Cup would be built
based on the fund system thousands of
migrants turned into construction
workers to build stadiums like Lucille
which became the site for human rights
abuses that range from verbal abuse to
death
several investigations into Qatar
stadiums revealed that employers usually
house workers in private camps far from
City centers where they are forced to
live in overcrowded rooms and unsanitary
conditions
and at work their lives are put at risk
migrant workers are often given the most
dangerous jobs on the site and can be
forced to work up to 14-hour days in
qatar's extreme heat
the day this photo of Lucille stadium
was taken the high reached 114 degrees
Fahrenheit they have spent so many hours
in the blistering sun and after that
they are only permitted a five minute
break to eat and they eat standing and
then go back whenever you're also up on
a scaffolding coming down for a bathroom
break might get you in trouble with your
boss and so you end up drinking less
water despite the need to have it to
avoid heat exhaustion the number of
work-related migrant deaths surrounding
stadiums remains unclear due to qatar's
lack of transparency
in fact that's the case with the entire
kafala system but there have been some
Clues along the way
the death certificates Nepal has
received with the bodies sent back from
Qatar show that nearly 120 Nepalese
migrants have died on the job since
2008. the real number though is likely
much higher
in 2019 a study examined the link
between Nepali worker deaths and heat
exposure and concluded heat stroke was a
likely cause of cardiovascular deaths
that alone could raise the number of
just Nepali migrant worker deaths to
about 600.
in addition to living and working in
abusive conditions many are also not
getting paid for their work
ERS have repeatedly faced wage theft so
that the debt keeps jacking off because
the death still exists and uh in many
cases workers have still not been able
to survive on a daily basis
the richest countries in the world and
yet they have been able to accelerate
reforms and insurance
some workers try to file complaints only
to find their few effective mechanisms
in place and speaking out comes with
risk of retaliation which has kept
migrants isolated in the Kabbalah system
with increasing debt and unable to
access Justice
[Music]
after years of mounting pressure from
Human Rights organizations and a formal
complaint that reached the un's
international labor organization in 2017
Qatar signed an agreement promising to
align its laws and labor practices to
International standards in 2020 10 years
after construction for the World Cup
began Qatar implemented a minimum wage
for workers and now allows them to
terminate their Employment contract but
the challenge with the minimum wage laws
is enforcement employers started pushing
back against the government and so even
though we haven't seen amendments to the
legislation indeed we're seeing a
watering down of reforms and for the
migrants who have already been abused
with the kafala system this is all too
late civil rights groups and football
associations are now calling for a
remedy fund to compensate the migrant
workers financially and some teams have
taken a stand in the field and on social
media we have learned the decision to
host the World Cup in Qatar which
resulted in suffering and in the harm of
countless of our fellow workers making
this year's World Cup a particularly
difficult one to watch
millions of football fans will still
tune in and cheer for their favorite
teams
but after that final match is over and
the trophy is awarded stadiums like
Lucille will continue to be a grim
reminder that it all came at a human
cost
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]